le professeur de l'unique elle donne le
tempo à suivre pour jouer du djembé et
pour ses stagiaires du week-end non
maîtrisé cet instrument de percussion
requiert concentration et souplesse
d'esprit ne sait pas tout n'est pas non
comme on dit dans la force non cette
pratique ni djembé donc et danses
traditionnelles
l'association lancé il ya un an par
justine et basile propose des cours et
des stages à près de 300 personnes
du simple cours d'une heure facturé 10
euros à 2 70 euros pour l'abonnement
annuel
une manière pour basile de transposition
savoir et de financer la construction
d'un centre culturel douala sa région à
tarbes là bas dans mon village à presque
6 10 personnes il en accueille troyes
qui semblent y mets moi-même 10 à espaly
écrit donc du coup pour m'imposer ici
sur visite d avoir besoin de quelqu'un à
chaque fois donc voilà pourquoi le
projet d'écrire l'association matter n'y
a qu'un pas ce qu'est ce qu'est avec le
concert conférence était là bas pour
essayer de créer un centre cultuel pour
que les enfants fin de la langue
française il espère récolter 40 mille
euros d'ici cinq ans pour monter cette
structure on se fixe comme objectif des
pouvoirs gagner 1000 euros par ménage
à chaque événement petit à petit ce
couple s'attaque en tout cas un cas
inquiétants côte d'ivoire selon les
dernières statistiques de l'unesco plus
d'un jeune on n'y voit rien sur deux il
est analphabète en 2016
[Musique]